vous le savez les mesures de police
sanitaire prise depuis plusieurs mois
ont permis de limiter la propagation du
virus elles ont permis d'éviter la
saturation de nos services de
réanimation mais l'épidémie circulent
toujours activement en france comme
d'ailleurs en europe et dans une large
partie du monde
la circulation d'épidémie se maintient à
un niveau élevé plus de 18000 cas par
jour
on peut parler de deux plateaux au
légèrement ascendant elle tend
potentiellement à s'accélérer de nouveau
sous le coup notamment de l'apparition
de ces variants dont on parle beaucoup
et qui ont provoqué dans des pays autour
de nous des flambées épidémiques que
nous cherchons à éviter par tous les
moyens et je dis nous sommes dans une
course contre la montre contre la
diffusion de ces variants depuis le
début de l'année 2020 l'épidémie a déjà
causé plus de 71 1000 décès dans notre
pays ces derniers jours il y avait plus
de vingt-cinq passivement 5000 patients
encore hospitalisés à l'hôpital et près
de 2800 patients en réanimation une
augmentation 1 par rapport à la semaine
dernière d'ailleurs laissé tous ses
éléments accumulés font courir le risque
accru d'une reprise épidémique en début
en dépit des mesures prises et récemment
renforcé pour limiter les importations
de cas de variants depuis ie l'étranger
l'état d'urgence sanitaire est déclarée
depuis le 17 octobre 2020 sur l'ensemble
du territoire national
hélas non du gouvernement il avait été
prorogé par le parlement jusqu'au 16
février 2021
le gouvernement a pu prendre s'ouvre sur
le fondement de l'article l 31 31-15 du
code de la santé publique les mesures
nécessaires et proportionnées à la
catastrophe sanitaire en limitant
notamment les déplacements des personnes
hors de leur domicile les rassemblements
sur la voie publique et dans les lieux
ouverts au public ainsi que l'accès à
certains établissements
aujourd'hui indicateurs épidémiologique
je vous le disais nous amène à demander
au législateur une prorogation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire c'est le sens de
l'article 2 du projet de loi qui prévoit
la prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire jusqu'au 1er juin 2021
l'article 1er je fais un peu dans le
désordre est également un article de
report de date puisqu'il s'agit de
reporter au 31 décembre 2021 c
voici le régime la caducité du régime
juridique d'état d'urgence sanitaire ici
initialement fixée au 1er avril 2021 par
l'article 7 de la loi du 23 mars 2020
cette clause de caducité proposées par
votre chambre au moment du vote de la
première loi d'état d'urgence sanitaire
a été inscrite à cet article 7
pérenniser dans le code de la santé
publique les outils qui peuvent être
actionnés en cas de crise sanitaire et
elle a raison du projet de loi que vous
le savez présenté en conseil des
ministres le 21 décembre dernier ce
texte a finalement été retiré de l'ordre
du jour il sera examiné au parlement une
fois la crise derrière nous comme le
gouvernement l'a annoncé aujourd'hui
n'est pas possible de se priver à partir
du 1er avril chacun peut le comprendre
d'un cadre juridique dédiée à la gestion
des phases les plus critiques de la
crise sanitaire c'est le sens de cet
article premier don qui proroge jusqu'au
31 décembre
le régime juridique j'ai entendu à
l'assemblée nationale et critique sur
les délais longs prévues par ce projet
de loi est ce qu'on prend le swell pour
le parlement d'avoir des clauses de
revoyure plus fréquentes
c'est ce qui a conduit lors de l'examen
en commission à l'assemblée nationale à
la suppression de l'article 3 qui
prévoyait initialement une prorogation
jusqu'au 30 septembre du régime de
sortie l'état d'urgence sanitaire sur
laquelle nous n'avons pas proposé de
revenir
donc nous avons accepté de suppression
de l'article 3 on va se dire les choses
franchement si la situation sanitaire à
la crise sanitaire devait être amené à
durer ce qui est une possibilité non
négligeable il est tout à fait en tout
cas je juge totalement légitime de me
représenter devant les deux chambres
pour faire un point de situation et
vérifier que les outils nous dont nous
disposons les pouvoirs que nous vous
demandons de nous conférer dans cette
situation exceptionnelle sont
proportionnées à la situation sanitaire
donc c'est en quelque sorte déjà
l'engagement que nous prenons avec la
suppression de l'article 3 de revenir
devant vous avant l'été pour faire un
point et éventuellement prolonger les
outils on ne veut pas non plus se
départir d'outils de gestion de crise
sanitaire au coeur de l'été on a vu
l'été dernier qu'il avait été utile même
indispensable de disposer des outils
juridiques nous permettant par exemple
de prononcer la fermeture précoce des
bars et des restaurants à marseille ou
encore des mesures de couvre-feu
territoriales je le redis au coeur de
l'été au mois d'août
l'article 4 prolonge jusqu'au 31
décembre 2020
t1 la possibilité de recourir aux outils
numériques contact coville et sidney
absolument indispensable surtout avec le
développement de notre stratégie tester
tracé tester alerté protéger et enfin
l'article 5 et en outre-mer les
dispositions qui le nécessitent
l'arrivée sur les sénateurs vous
connaissez très bien ce texte mais je
suis à votre disposition pour toutes
précisions questions d'orientation
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
monsieur reporter urba monsieur le
ministre je trouve que vous proposons
dans le sens de l'apaisement de nos
relations
car nous avons toujours été extrêmement
attentif à ce que les restrictions
nécessaires à l'exercice d'un certain
nombre de libertés fondamentales pour
lutter contre cette crise sanitaire soit
sarthe soit assortie d'un contrôle
régulier et approfondie du parlement par
conséquent j'apprécie vos déclarations
celles que vous avez faite hier à
l'assemblée nationale et que vous
reproduisez presque exactement c'est
votre cohérence devant notre commission
oui nous pensons que l'enchaînement de
mesures prises au titre du régime de
sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire et
de mesures prises au type de l'urgence
sanitaire ne devrait pas se faire sans
un vote du parlement et par conséquent
nous apprécions que vous ayez accepté la
suppression demandé par la commission de
l'assemblée nationale de votre article 3
parce que cet article 3 permettait de
continuer à prendre après le mois de
juin des mesures qu'ils sont ni le
confinement ni le couvre feu généralisé
mais qui sont tout de même des mesures
fortement restrictive des libertés et
nous considérons c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle nous n'avons pas
trouvé d'accord avec l'assemblée
nationale en juillet dernier ni en
lambres dernier que de telles mesures
quand elles sont dûment justifiée et
proportionnée aux exigences du
traitement de la crise sanitaire ne doit
pas pouvoir être prise sans que le
parlement est à voter donc le nous
rapprochons d'un dispositif dans lequel
nous pouvons vous inscrire nous avons
fauté en marche on met en juillet qu'en
novembre et même pour les textes qui
finalement n'ont pas été approuvées par
le sénat
cette possibilité pour le gouvernement
d'exercer des pouvoirs exceptionnels
face à la crise il faut bien qu'on se
comprenne
quand tu ne nous sommes pas mis d'accord
c'est pas que nous pensions qu'il
fallait baisser la garde dans la lutte
contre l'épidémie
c'est parce que nous pensions au
contraire il fallait prendre des mesures
sévères et qui dit mesures sévères dit
contrôle accru du parlement c'est ça
notre approche générale et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle c'est
la commission des lois qui se prononce
sur ce sujet et non pas la commission en
charge de la santé
même si nous sommes en lien les uns avec
les autres
notre accord pour mettre en oeuvre des
restrictions liberté suppose qu'elles
soient temporaires que le parlement soit
appelé à voter régulièrement et bien sûr
que le juge constitutionnel est juge
administratif s'assure de la
proportionnalité des mesures prises en
application de la loi par le
gouvernement
les restrictions qui sont prises pour
lutter contre le covan 19 sont beaucoup
plus importantes que celles qu'on prend
pour le terrorisme
ça donne la mesure exacte des
disciplines qui sont imposés aux
français qui mettre entre parenthèses
des conditions d'une vie normale je ne
rentre pas dans le détail puisque nous
manquons un peu de temps simplement une
course contre la montre est engagée pour
apprécier la durée pendant laquelle nous
sommes prêts à autoriser le gouvernement
à utiliser ces pouvoirs exceptionnels
nous avons besoin d'en savoir un peu
plus long sur le développement de la
campagne de vaccination dans mon esprit
plus on aura vite vacciner les français
moins on aura besoin de restreindre leur
liberté et par conséquent avant de
s'engager sur une date
nous avons vraiment besoin de vous
entendre sur ce point précis nous sommes
sensibles aux difficultés qui sont
apparus dès le lancement de la campagne
de vaccination
nous avons compris que le gouvernement a
adapté son dispositif est tenu compte du
premier retour d'expérience mais nous
constatons néanmois parce que nous
sommes sénateurs parce que nous sommes
en contact avec nos préfets et nos mères
avec nos concitoyens des territoires
qu'il y a toujours des difficultés
nous voyons bien que l'accès au vaccin
ne se fait pas même pour les populations
cibles et il n'est pas question d autres
dans des conditions qui sont optimales
nous avons constaté en effet que le
nombre de personnes vaccinées en france
ne cesse de croître et qu'on va plus
vite maintenant qu'il y a quinze jours
mais nous nous demandons si vous
arriverez à atteindre vos objectifs en
matière de vaccination sans prendre de
nouvelles dispositions qui tiendrait
davantage compte de l'offre de service
qui vous est faite par beaucoup de
collectivités par beaucoup de médecins
réunis par ces collectivités et
d'infirmiers pour la mise en place de
centres de vaccination notre inquiétude
au fond c'est que
le rationnement du vaccin les
difficultés d'accès les rendez-vous des
commandes et les rendez vous que les
personnes âgées ont du mal à prendre
notre avis le développement de la
vaccination et vous force dans quelques
mois ou quelques semaines à revenir vers
nous pour nous demander d'autoriser de
nouvelles restrictions aux libertés
je ne rentre pas dans plus de questions
parce que tom
dans mon esprit c'est vraiment ça
aujourd'hui qui est l'essentiel
et quand je me retournerai vers mes
collègues pour leur faire des
propositions sur les dates ce que vous
allez nous dire maintenant contrainte et
un merci monsieur suba monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le rapporteur lorsque
vous avez à mener une campagne de
vaccination à l'échelle de plusieurs
millions de personnes
vous avez pas 36 façons d'envisager les
choses
vous en avez 2 me semble-t-il mais suis
preneur de vos remarques et vos
compositions rayant sincérité quand vous
avez par exemple un public cible de
quelques 6,4 millions de personnes
auxquelles j'ajoute plus de 500 mille
professionnels de santé 1 millions de
ps2 résidents en ehpad qui est public
donc des plus de 75 ans d'être est très
vulnérable et des personnes en perte
d'autonomie
donc on est à peu près sûr un public 2-8
minot personnes vous avez deux options
je le disais l'option numéro une
vous attendez d'avoir 8 millions de
vaccins x 2 puisqu'il faut le rappel
vaccinal et lorsque vous avez ce tous
les vaccins à disposition vous inviter
les gens à se présenter si vous faites
une campagne éclair de vaccination c'est
faire tous les moyens en multipliant les
centres pendant la grippe on est capable
de faire une vaccination d'un million de
personnes par jour en utilisant tous les
réseaux pharmaceutiques etc
et c'est le choix que nous avons fait et
c'est aussi le choix de tous les pays
européens où vacciner à flux tendu à
chaque livraison de vaccins
vous les utilisez sans attendre
vous avez là plusieurs complexité qui
apparaissent dans le cas qui nous qui
nous réunit 1 vous le savez le vaccin
files heures et comme le vaccin moderna
ne sont pas des vaccins qui sont
utilisables en pharmacie d'officine au
quotidien et pas non plus dans les
cabinets médecine de ville pour décrire
condition évidente de conservation moins
70 degrés une fois décongelés moins de
douze heures de transport et puis moins
de cinq jours pour les utiliser des
flacons ouvert de 5 à 6 doses ce qui
fait qu on ne peut pas se permettre d'en
perdre qui je perds mais dix vingt ou
trente pour cent des quantités de
vaccins disponibles en raison d'une
organisation vaccinale chez le droit à
une convocation devant les deux
assemblées et il me serait difficile d'y
répondre en tout cas de façon cette
seconde peau donc la vaccination fut
tendu ça sous-entendre que vous avez un
rythme de livraisons de vaccins et que
vous mettez en corrélation ce rythme de
livraisons de vaccins avec un rythme de
vaccination
ce que je veux dire c'est que l'enjeu
pour nous n'est pas un enjeu
d'organisation c'est un enjeu
d'approvisionnement et d'arrivée des
doses un public de 8 millions de
personnes
deux millions de vaccins disponibles à
date
500000 vaccins livrés par semaine puis
un million de vaccins a livré par
semaine vous voyez qu avant d'arriver à
pouvoir proposer aux 8 millions publics
prioritaires
un vaccin il faut que nous ayons eu
suffisamment d'arrivage et
d'approvisionnement pour pouvoir le
faire mais néanmoins nous commençons à
vacciner parce qu'à chaque fois que nous
vaccinons des personnes fragiles au
regard de la maladie eh bien nous
gagnons du temps sur la saturation des
hôpitaux et nous évitons à des personnes
de tomber gravement malade
c'est à la fois je vous le dis le
l'enjeu pour la france en jeu pour
l'allemagne pour l'italie pour l'espagne
etc
en france nous avons eu un démarrage
différente du démarrage allemand mais
indien démarche totalement et qui veut
leur par exemple à celui de la belgique
ou des pays bas ou de bien d'autres pays
européens qui a consisté à dire que nous
nous ciblions nous avons divisé le
public prioritaire de 1800 personnes en
deux un public d'un million de personnes
en ehpad que nous avons jugé ultra
prioritaire et pour lequel nous
disposions d'un million de doses et
ensuite des clés 2 arriverait
l'ouverture aux soignants 50 ans et plus
etc etc et vous connaissez la suite
les publics en ehpad je ne reviens pas
sur tous ces sujets là certains m'ont
dit pourquoi ne pas avoir demandé les
consentements des personnes âgées en
ehpad
avant que les vaccins sont livrés
puisqu'on savait que les vaccins
arrivent rennes 28 décembre
c'est totalement logique j même temps
c'est mais c'était totalement impossible
parce qu' il n'était pas question et les
fédérations d pad ont été très clairs
sur ce point je pense qu'elles ont brûlé
raison il n'était pas question de
recueillir un consentement ou vérifier
quelqu'un peut être compatible avec la
vaccination pour un vaccin qui n'était
non seulement pas validé par les
autorités européennes du médicament et
pour lequel par essence
nous ne disposions n'ont ni d indication
ni des contre indications éventuelles
donc il nous fallait attendre le feu
vert de l'ema pour commencer à organiser
cela nous étions alors dans la période
de noël puis du nouvel an avec des
médecins coordonnateurs qui prennent et
c'est tout à fait normal
un peu de congé des personnes âgées en
ehpad qui parfois ont la chance de
pouvoir partir dans leur famille et puis
des familles dont on a besoin d'avoir
l'aval lorsque la personne ne peut pas
donner son accord elle même qui elles
mêmes sont dispersées parce que c'est la
période des vacances
donc nous avons organisé un tout un
planning d'organisation de distribution
de ces vaccins
j'ajoute la contrainte de transport qui
fait que vous ne pouvez pas avoir un
seul camion qui partiraient d'un centre
de stockage pour faire le tour d'un
département
il nous faut autant de camions qu'il ya
de trajet de voitures à faire pour ne
pas sacrifier le brin d'adn arn messager
qui est si fragile dans les transports
et ses plans de transport qui ont été
fait en concertation totale et
permanente avec les fédérations d pad et
vous voyez que la campagne les ehpad a
très bien démarré
cent soixante mille personnes âgées et
soignant n'est pas de vaccinés seront
vaccinés cette semaine 150 me de la
semaine prochaine et quelques cent mille
dernier la semaine suivante puis
commencera d'ailleurs la commencer je
pense à à cette brave morissette qui a
eu son rappel vaccinal tout à fait
normalement cette semaine
donc nous avons néanmoins amplifiés et
accélérés avec en amplifiant la
stratégie du flux tendus pour vacciner
d'abord les soignants de 50 ans et plus
et puis nous avons ouvert plutôt que
nous ce que nous avions prévu la
vaccination pour les 75 ans et plus en
ville ce faisant l'organisation en flux
tendu entraîne nécessairement et vous
pouvez parfaitement le comprendre et
entendre malgré toute la bonne volonté
des soignants des élus et des
administrations des logiques de soap and
go des logiques de stop and go
je vais vous définir les choses plus
précisément je serai pas trop long mais
j'insiste puisqu'on m'avait dit c'est un
point qui était important pour vous
j'avais parlé de 300 centres de
vaccination ouverts à l'échelle du pays
d'ici à la fin du mois de janvier et
puis nous montrerions à 6 ans entre nous
sommes quasiment à 1000 centres
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de beaucoup
d'allant beaucoup d'entrain beaucoup de
volonté des élus locaux et c'est tant
mieux qu'ils ont valeur préfère dix ans
mais moi et on peut le comprendre j'ai
un gymnase qui ne sert pas depuis des
semaines
j'ai du personnel de mairie que je peux
mettre à disposition du centre de
vaccination je les médecins de ma
commune qui sont d'accord pour venir
j'ai une sage femme libérale retraités
qui est prête à venir filer un coup de
main et à vacciner
j'ai toute l'organisation qui est mise
en place le préfet accrédités mon centre
vaccinons c'est ainsi qu'on se retrouve
en lieu et place des six centres que
j'avais exigé en moyenne dans le
département avec certains départements
qui cumulent jusqu'à 33 centres de
vaccination monsieur le sénateur vous
comprenez parfaitement qu'une fois qu'un
centre est ouvert la personne qui
l'organisent ce centre elle a envie de
vacciner ce qui est tout à fait normal
mais c'est pas parce que vous ouvrirez
plus de centre que vous avez plus de
vaccins est donc cette répartition se re
dispatching des vaccins qui avait été
provisionnée pour six centres par
département dans une multitude de
centres un peu entraîné des sites des
jeux le trash je traduirai sa part ok il
ya des mécanismes de hockey dans un
certain nombre de départements on en
compte environ 30 départements qui ont
procédé à ce qu'on appelle du coup du
surbooking c'est à dire qu'ils se sont
retrouvés avec un peu plus de créneaux
qui n'avait de doses une quinzaine de
départements pour lesquels on a
solutionné le problème et une quinzaine
d'autres dans lesquelles nous allons
demander à ce département de maintenir
les créneaux de vaccination qui ont été
ouverts au pire dans les cas critiques
je pense à la région de france dans
certains endroits ou de france leur
demandons de différer d'une à deux
semaines les vaccinations qui avait été
organisée mais donna nu les personnes et
donc d'utiliser par anticipation les
doses en flux tendu qui aurait dû leur
permettre de faire des primo vaccination
février si je résume
c'est à dire que les centres et qui ont
fait preuve de beaucoup d'enthousiasmé
et qui vaccinent beaucoup plus que prévu
en janvier
noront pour seule vaccination au mois de
février que les rappels de vaccination
qui ça c'est une point sur lequel je
suis absolument intransigeant avec tout
le monde
toute personne qui provoque signer doit
avoir son rappel et nous ferons donc
quasiment plus de primo vaccination
février puisque l'augmentation des
livraisons n'est pas linéaire et qu'elle
se fait par paliers c'est ça à
l'organisation face à laquelle nous
sommes aujourd'hui est ce que je fais
fermé
entre par les préfets dans les
départements dont je vous avais dit 6
allée maximum 10 à entrer en admis en a
plus aujourd'hui où est-ce qu'on
maintient naissante qui font qu'ils ont
l'avantagé d'offrir la proximité aux
populations les choix la proximité c'est
un choix que j'ai fait dès le début ça
fois que j'ai fait dès le début parce
que je ne voulais pas qu'on ait 50
centrales allemandes où les gens ferait
une heure et demie de voiture et frais
trois heures de queue devant un grand
gymnase en plein hiver à l'âge de 85 ans
je crois qu'on peut on peut s'entendre
sur ce point
donc voilà maintenant vous avez encore
beaucoup d'élus qui avec beaucoup
d'allant nous disent mais nous aussi on
va ouvrir notre centre est pourquoi on
nous empêche regarde et c'est le
problème n'est pas le centre le problème
c'est l'approvisionnement en vaccins et
que si vous avez j'ai vu qu'il ya un
centre par exemple qui fait 30 de
vaccinations par jour
c'est sans doute très bien enfin vous
mobiliser des soignants du personnel de
mairie des bâtiments pour trente deux
vaccinations par jour peut-être faut-il
regrouper un peu là où c'est nécessaire
de manière à ce que l on gagne aussi en
efficacité toujours est-il monsieur le
sénateur qui erre et avant-hier nous
avons réalisé plus de 100000
vaccinations par jour 108 mille hier
pour être précis ce qui fait que nous
sommes à un rythme fois deux au
quotidien par rapport à l'allemagne par
exemple et que j'avais annoncé au début
du mois de janvier qui me fallait pas
s'affoler et que le rythme de
vaccination en france allait partir très
fort et que nous rattrape riom notre
retard si tant est qu'on puisse
considérer que sont en retard parce que
quatre jours de décalage winn dixie
nation n'a pas de conséquence entre des
publics et donc nous avait annoncé
l'objectif d'un million de vaccinations
à la fin du mois de janvier nous serons
très au delà de ce million de
vaccinations
mais en flux tendu en flux tendu et les
selles doses que nous conservons et que
les centres concerts sont les doses qui
sont indispensables pour assurer le
rappel vaccinal des personnes qui ont
été primés vacciner
je ne garde en stock national que huit
mille doses sur les 2 millions tout le
reste est déployée dans les centres dans
l'ensemble des territoires
il ya au moins un centre de stockage par
département ainsi que dans les
territoires ultramarins
on peut toujours faire mieux mais je
vous dirais et ça ça vous intéressera en
particulier enfin mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs c'est que on a fait le
choix d'une politique
déconcentré et un peu décentralisés
on aurait pu faire un choix d'une
politique hyper concentré
j'aurais pu dire c'est moi qui vais dire
combien de vaccins j'en vois dans tel
centre et organiser nous-mêmes les
plannings et avoir 30 40 centres au
niveau du pays
on aurait pu avoir une politique
totalement décentralisé en donnant des
vaccins à une collectivité alors disant
écoutez vous vous organiser on a fait le
choix d'une politique déconcentré qui
repose sur l'intervention des préfets
des ars et des zébus et ils sont réunis
dans des cellules corps digne de
coordination territoriale pour
déterminer quel centre quelle dose etc
et on s'appuie énormément sur les
hôpitaux et je les remercie pour leur
mobilisation
sa petite idée concentré on se serait
intéressant d'avoir un retour
d'expérience je vais me fait déjà une
petite idée parce que finalement la
responsabilité incombe toujours à l'état
central
quand bien même on à onna je dirais
organiser la responsabilité au sein des
territoires
c'est ainsi donc moi je suis très
confiant sur notre capacité non
seulement à maintenir un bon rythme des
vaccinations
je suis intransigeant sur la demande que
je fais à tous les centres d'organiser
la deuxième taxi nation c'est à dire le
rappel pour les gens korité primo
vacciner j'anticipe mais c'est le cas de
l'allemagne aujourd'hui qu'il y aura un
moment donné une réduction des primes
aux vaccinations à mesure que les
rappels de vaccination augmenteront
parce que ça consommera des doses et
enfin pour répondre à votre question et
ça justifie l'échéance du 1er juin
nous ciblons 15 millions de personnes
vaccinées d'ici avant l'été notre dessin
représente une grosse partie de la
population à risque de formes graves
quoique si on ajoute toutes les
personnes qui sont en maladie chronique
plus les personnes âgées de 60 ans et
plus on est plus proche des 25 à 30
millions de personnes
ce qui veut dire que même avec la
meilleure organisation et tous les
approvisionnements qui arriverait en
temps et en heure nous ne pourrions
avoir actionné toutes les plumes tout
l'époque tous les publics fragiles d'ici
à l'été raison pour laquelle nous
demandons la poursuite d'ailleurs de
mesures de protection sanitaire jusqu'à
l'automne c'est mathématiquement c'est
mathématiquement me semble-t-il
défendable voilà j'étais long de ma
réponse mais j'espère vous avoir apporté
ces éléments c'est un contexte qui s'y
prêtent davantage qu'une tribune
d'hémicycle et je vous fais confiance
pour me poser toutes les questions
complémentaires que vous souhaiterez
merci monsieur lui seulement je pourrais
peut-être tout de suite une question à
partir du moment où vous faites un choix
de
de stratégie et de logistique qu'on
entend quelles sont les capacités
d'avoir aujourd'hui plus de vaccins plus
de production de vaccins et quelle est
la télévision vous avez de
l'augmentation de cette fourniture de
vaccins en fait j'ai envie de vous dire
que j'aimerais avoir autant de vaccins
que prévu
ça va dépendre de plusieurs paramètres 1
la capacité des labos à honorer leurs
commandes
on a vu qu'on a déjà un ralentissement
des approvisionnements par rapport à ce
qui était prévu de la part des grands
labos qui concerne la france l'europe le
québec guerre et puis la validation
d'autres vaccins à venir parler par le m
à l' agence du médicament européenne
quelle est la nature des indications qui
seront à conférer à ces vaccins par le
m&a et en fait il ya toujours une marge
d'incertitude est important ceux ci
imaginons que dans deux semaines ou dans
trois semaines le m&a nous dise
astrazeneca est utilisable chez les
personnes âgées vous pouvez y aller
c'est pour moi c'est le bonheur total
on a des millions de doses qui nous
arrivent chaque mois il est à
conservation classique il est injecté à
blanc pharmacie ou chez un médecin
on peut alors là vous nous livrez 3
millions de doses à la fin de la semaine
elles sont des potées ses fils et on en
parle plus il imaginait que le m&a nous
disent y'a pas à ces personnes âgées
dans l'étude du laboratoire
vous ne pouvez pas utiliser astrazeneca
pour les personnes âgées je vais devoir
ouvrir un nouveau circuit parallèle à au
circuit actuel qui pourra se faire sans
doute dans les mêmes conditions
officines médecins etc mais qui devra
cibler un public qui n'est pas un public
de personnes âgées et donc on aura
j'anticipe aussi des polémiques mais les
polémiques souvent naissent des
incompréhensions ça peut être mais
parfois anticiper une polémique essayé
de l'expliquer par avance ne levitte pas
quand elle doit survenir elle survient
avec plus ou moins de talent de la part
de ceux qui là qu'ils entretiennent mais
donc c'est pour vous dire que tout cela
va avoir un impact forcément très
important dans notre capacité à protéger
le public vulnérable et dans les délais
quant à notre capacité de renforcer les
commandes ont d'abord vous dire que les
commandes elles ont été passées par la
commission européenne c'est une aventure
européenne que cette campagne vaccinale
des mois des mois avant que les vaccins
soient validées c'est le pari presque
fou qu'on aurait pu nous reprocher
dans tous les sens sénat c'est un mec
pas abouti qu'a fait l'europe d'aller
passer des contrats de commande pour des
centaines de millions de doses de vaccin
auprès de laboratoires qui nous disait
que la recherche était avancée mais pour
lesquels nous ne disposions même pas des
données nécessaires pour sécuriser les
choses alors évidemment il ya eu un
travail très sérieux qui était avec les
scientifiques à la fois la commission
européenne et de laboratoires permettant
de déterminer quels vaccins avait une
chance d'aboutir
mais pour l'instant c'est carton plein
tant mieux enfin encore une fois quel
pari que d'avoir acheté il ya six mois
des vaccins qui n'était ni produits dits
validé par anticipation donc on peut se
targuer d'avoir une europe qui a très
bien fonctionné
sap a tué toujours été le cas dans la
crise sanitaire elle a très bien
fonctionné et nous permet de couvrir
tous les besoins et largement la
population européenne d'ici un horizon
quelques mois nous déployons nos
capacités industrielles françaises et
européennes pour renforcer la production
de vaccins c'est le cas de trois
entreprises pharmaceutiques en france
qui n'ont rien à voir avec les
laboratoires qui détiennent les brevets
mais pour lesquels les ces deux
laboratoires nous disent ok vous voulez
produire en plus c'est notamment fareva
qui va produire 2 qui produit du curve
ac en finale finit ce qu'on appelle le
final finish et de le produit fini du du
vaccin c'est l'étape la plus la plus
longue finalement de reproduction
paradoxalement et où nous avons sétif
armes qui produit du moderna et delta
farm qui produit du finder
nous travaillons également avec une
grande industrie dans le siège social
est en france sanofi pour qu'elle puisse
en coopération avec les laboratoires qui
ont déjà trouvé un vaccin tout en
continuant ses recherches et
développements sur son propre vaccin
nous aider à produire davantage pour
l'europe
ça prend du temps une entreprise une
usine de fabrication de produits
pharmaceutiques qui décide de faire du
film un finish pour le compte d'un
laboratoire pour du vaccin
il faut au moins deux à trois mois pour
que ça démarre ça a été fait ça a été
fait le démarrage est imminent et cela
renforcera nos capacités
d'approvisionnement mais je vous dirais
une chose et j'arrêterai là on est dans
la phase en moins d'un an des
laboratoires eu un brevet pour un vaccin
et ils ont heureusement commencé à
produire en masse
leur vaccin avant d'avoir le revers et
avant d'avoir la validation mais le
temps de production est un temps qui est
incompressible
c'est pas une affaire d'état c'est une
affaire de production en tant que tel et
donc ce temps de production ils
produisent un milliard un milliard et
demi de vaccins par mois donc plus le
temps passe plus leurs capacités de
production sont importantes plus leurs
livraisons sont importantes et plus on
se protégera on est ici dans la phase je
dirais pas d'anticipation mais dans la
phase initiale d'une campagne vaccinale
qui va prendre de l'ampleur
et si vous regardez les chiffres que
nous avons publiée en transparence sur
les arrivages d approvisionnement en
vaccins
oui d'ici à quelques mois n'aurons pas
cinq cent mille doses par semaine mais
aux rondes nous aurons des millions et
donc forcément nous augmenterons le
rythme des vaccinations mais tout cela
prendra du temps et je les dis aux
françaises et aux français quand il je
les ai invités à prendre rendez vous
pour se faire vacciner
je leur ai dit attention tout le monde
ne sera pas vaccinés en février et tout
le monde ne sera peut-être pas vaccinés
en mars
ça va prendre du temps mais nous
commençons à le faire à flux tendu et
chaque fois qu'une et l'un d'entre vous
est vacciné et se voit protéger contre
les formes graves de virus et bien nous
gagnons du terrain sur le virus
merci monsieur lui la parole est à
monsieur le comte
puis madame turc erman monsieur turin
merci aux surgères également sous la
présidence de monsieur le ministre
quelques quelques questions d'abord une
remarque de se satisfaire que le
gouvernement n'est pas mis en place de
mesures totalement contrôlé d'isolement
absolu et est surveillé pour des
personnes qui sont co vit plus comme on
le voit dans un certains autres pays
européens quand on voit les évolutions
dans ces pays à des stratégies
d'évitement qui aujourd'hui conduisent à
avoir des développements de l'épidémie
qui sont plus important qu'en france si
je le dis c'est parce que je
je perçois que peut-être vous pourriez
évolué avec la parution des variants et
vous demandez affirmé que c'est
probablement pas comme ça qu'on pourra
faire face à cela deuxièmement nous dit
le rap a bien fonctionné durant la crise
sanitaire
alors je vais vous poser la question du
passeport vaccinale ou gouvernement
visiblement a peu évolué entre le projet
de loi mort-né du mois de décembre et
les positions que clément boon a exprimé
à quelques jours toutefois on voit qu'un
nombre de pays importants veulent aller
dans cette direction très vite
même avant que chacun puisse que ceux
qui le souhaitent puissent être vaccinés
est ce que vous pensez que vous pleurez
résister et comment vous abordez cette
négociation européenne
de la même manière avec l'apparition des
variants heureusement que finalement ça
s'est passé en grande bretagne puisqu'il
séquence le virus de manière assez
systématique est ce que vous pensez
qu'avec le fichier cidep tel que nous
l'avons et l'organisation que nous avons
nous sommes en mesure de bien identifier
l'apparition de deux nouveaux variants
en france et concernant les propositions
des prises de positions en particulier
dans gala merkel ces derniers jours est
ce que vous pensez que l'on peut arriver
à une situation où il y aura des des
quarantaines au passage les frontières
intra européennes
comment gérera les frontaliers dans ces
conditions est ce que franchement les
frontières européennes sont des
frontières pertinente pour surveiller
des des foyers spécifiques qui
pourraient être touchés par des parts
des variants voilà parce que je pense
que ce mal on reviendrait à la question
numéro 1 et avec les risques des
stratégies d'évitement qui ne sont
jamais très bonne
merci monsieur le combat un pic herrmann
oui merci
monsieur ministre une il ya deux choses
je crois alors qu'ils vont bien
évidemment ensemble il ya la question
qui va nous être posée la semaine
prochaine d'une prolongation d'état
d'urgence la 7e qui inévitablement il y
est
à la situation vaccinale puisque je
crois que en tout cas nous sommes tous
conscients c'est bien et vous venez de
le rappeler d'ailleurs c'est bien de la
réussite d'une vaccination généralisée à
terme que nous pourrons sortir en tout
cas de de seyssuel de ces situations là
puisque j'ose imaginer que cette
situation d'état d'urgence est bien lié
à la situation sanitaire est que quand
nous serons sortis de celle ci nous
pouvons reprendre une vie normale en
tous points de vue tant dans nos
relations humaines que dans les rapports
à faire un certain nombre d'interdits
ma première question est donc la
suivante vous nous proposer une
prolongation d'état d'urgence j'ai
entendu ce que vous nous avez dit
rassuré son article 3 hier à l'assemblée
nationale cependant et nous l'avons déjà
dit ce n'est pas un handicap de
travailler avec le parlement et donc ce
délai jusqu'au 1er juin nous semble long
puisque dans les faits une fois le temps
législatif passé cela veut dire
quasiment que pendant près de quatre
mois
nous n'avons plus de retour et que le
parlement ne sera pas associé et je ne
précise pas ce que je tourne joue sur
les mots mais associer le parlement ce
n'est pas simplement venir le présenter
la situation
c'est bien c'est mieux que rien associés
locaux
ce n'est pas simplement non plus avoir
des préfets représentants de la rs etc
qui informe les élus locaux associés
c'est bien faire avec excusez moi je
n'ai pas de culture scientifique mais
plutôt littéraire d'autres voyages en
saurait en tout cas sur le sens des mots
la deuxième sur la vaccination pour le
coup moi je
ce qu'effectivement je ne sais pas si il
ya des bassins cacher je ne veux pas
alimenter en tout cas les craintes dans
ce domaine là une chose est sûre c'est
qu'il manque de vaccins il manque de
vaccins pour répondre alors j'entends ce
que vous venez de dire je ne vous ferai
pas ici l'affront de revenir avec un
débat qui n'a pas lieu d'être sur le
pourquoi du comment nous en sommes là
aujourd'hui nous en sommes là dans le
pays
vous l'avez redit de toutes les façons
quelles que soient les inflexions
fortement forte qui pourraient être
prises nous sommes dans des délais de
trois mois à partir du nom il faut
produire davantage en main en revanche
je veux revenir sur ce que vous avez dit
c'est à dire la possibilité aujourd'hui
puis pourrait y avoir de venir d'un
autre type de vaccin qui pourrait être
réservé à une autre partie de la
population et je pense qu'il faut quand
même qu'on visage et alors le président
de la commission des lois le disait mais
cela peut être complémentaires et peut
ne pas s'opposer en tout cas parce que
bien évidemment quand il y en a pas
beaucoup on les consacre aux plus
fragiles au plus aux personnes qui ont
le plus besoin d'être protégée mais si
nous en avions d'autres nous pourrions
réfléchir à une situation qui large je
ne veux pas opposer les populations
entre à lui nous avons spire notre
urgence dans notre pays c'est quand même
d'éviter la crise économique et sociale
qui menace à l'issue de cette crise
sanitaire
donc si demain nous avions les poster
avec un autre vaccin de vacciner une
classe d'âge
on va dire plus productives je pense que
le travail est important pour faire
société aussi je crois que ça ne doit
pas être exclue doit pouvoir être miné
en tout cas en parallèle un merci
monsieur queyranne monsieur du rhin
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous nous avez assuré être
disponible pour revenir vers le
parlement chaque fois ce sera nécessaire
et nous vous en remercions
je voulais attirer votre attention sur
un sujet qui me paraît essentiel c'est
l'épuisement moral de la population de
ce pays il ya d'impatience de
l'inquiétude de la frustration ça
commence à tourner la colère
le stop and go avec la fermeture de
certains centres de vaccination qui
avaient été ouverts provoque chez les
élus et unir qu'on peut qu'on peut
comprendre alors on a compris il ya
passé vaccins et vous avez dit que les
perspectives l'été non négligeable que
la crise dure assez longtemps
je pense qu'il faut une ligne d'horizon
et en attendant que l'on puissent
vacciner tous ceux qui en ont besoin
il faut que nous vivions avec avec cette
les gestes barrière avec la crise et à
ce titre vous avez été autorisé hier à
utiliser un certain nombre de systèmes
d'information on avait autorisé après
avoir beaucoup hésité
l'utilisation de tous antico vite je
voulais savoir si cet outil avait encore
la moindre utilité
je vous cite simplement l'exemple d'un
centre médical qui a vu passer 155
personnes qui étaient porteuses du virus
et pour lequel jamais l'application
n'est passé du vert au rouge donc est ce
que ça marche
et puis monsieur enfin monsieur richard
et monsieur le président il créé pour
suivre un instant les changes sur le
sujet de la montée du potentiel de
vaccination et ses effets sur le
déroulement de la crise
donc je peux retirer de votre
explication précédente que nous allons
passer au cours du trimestre en février
ou en mars d'un rythme de 1 million de
vaccins supplémentaires par semaine à
quelque chose qui s'approchera de 2
millions par semaine peut-être en mars
en fonction notamment de l'homologation
du vaccin
astrazeneca est donc c'est me
semble-t-il au tour de ceux de cette
évaluation de d'une montée du de la
production dans les usines d des
producteurs de vaccins et de leurs
sous-traitants
parce que cela sous traitance va se
développer c'est en février ou mars que
nous allons passer à un rythme supérieur
à 1 million par mois et qui nous donne
une chance en effet d'arriver à
l'objectif des 15 millions ou un peu
plus avant la fin du printemps
non je trouve que dans des mains
publiques 7e franchement utile de
poursuivre l'explication et la diffusion
de ces chiffres et de s'assurer puisque
nous sommes dépendants de scientifiques
et d'industriels et je veux redire
parce que le fruit hasard de la vie
personnelle me font partager des débats
avec des personnes qui sont dans ce
monde là c'est tout de même un fait
historique que personne ne prévoyait ya
six mois que nous ayons trois vaccins
effectivement validé dans le monde avec
des taux de 80% ou plus de réussite
produits en moins d'un an après
l'apparition d'un virus totalement
nouveau
tout le monde pensait et franchement je
dans le milieu scientifique
j'ai entendu beaucoup de personnes de
dire si on a de la chance on aura le
premier axe à la fin
21 donc on est on est tout de même dans
quelque chose qui relève de la part de
scientifiques et d'industriels un vilain
mot d'un d'un exploit majeur et qui
bénéficie à l'ensemble de l'humanité
mais simplement pour finir le chaînage
du raisonnement dans la tâche qui est la
nôtre fixer la loi le régime juridique
de l'état d'urgence il reste un chaînon
qui est qu'est ce que ça donne sur la
circulation du virus est ce qu'au fond
tout un chacun étant vacciner donc on va
arriver à 3 % 15 % 5 % de la population
quand on sera à 15 millions dans cinq ou
six mois nous serons à 25% de la
population
est ce que ce taux de vaccination en
progression à fait substantiellement la
circulation du virus moi ce que j'ai
retenu des expressions scientifique dial
du jour dix jours quinze jours c'est
premièrement en gros ne sais pas et
deuxièmement on a quand même une
première perception que pour des formes
bénignes mais qui donc assure une
certaine circulation la diffusion du
vaccin ne freine pas substantiellement
la circulation du virus
donc quand nous responsables politiques
au nom des citoyens nous fixons des
règles de limitation de toutes les
interactions de toutes les activités
publiques susceptibles de favoriser la
circulation en gros mais sur sur ce
point là je me dis ceci un peu du
raisonnement présenté par philippe va
tout à l'heure il n'est pas sûr et ne
tourne pas tenir pour acquis qu'une
progression à hauteur de 5 ou 10 % de la
population de la vaccination réduisent
en quoi que ce soit la circulation du
virus donc j'aimerais bien
vous entendre sur cet élément là du
chaînage de du raisonnement et la
responsabilité politique
merci monsieur richard de la parole
monsieur mini coup deux questions ça
marche on va essayer des plus cons si
tout allait d'abord sur les contraintes
l isolement ce n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour et avec leur ministre nous avons
concerté l'ensemble des présidents de
groupes des deux chambres parlementaires
et nous avons vu qu'à part une exception
l'ensemble de la classe politique était
opposé à des contraintes à l'isolément
en tout cas dans ledroit jaillir
d'endroits comme un extraordinaire
qu'est l'état d'urgence sanitaire donc
nous n'avons pas poussé le pion plus
loin et ne vont pas mis en place ce type
de dispositions qui nous et ce n'est pas
sur la table du gouvernement
j'attire votre attention sur le fait
qu'il peut y avoir des arrêtés
préfectoraux de placement en isolement
pour des personnes qui individuellement
ne sont pas amenés où sont amenés à ne
pas respecter le confinement et mettant
en danger la population la santé de la
population c'est le cas notamment pour
certaines personnes qui ont été
contractées le variant étrangers et qui
n'étaient pas de nature à respecter kiné
qui avaient fait leur valoir leur
décision de ne pas respecter isolement
pour lesquels un arrêté préfectoral a
été pris mais c'est d'un arrêté
préfectoral individuel sur la question
du passeport vaccinale c'est beaucoup
trop tôt au fond pour avoir cette
question mais on est normal de vouloir
anticiper de se projeter dans l'avenir
mais c'est beaucoup trop tôt pour poser
cette question ça rejoint d'ailleurs une
intervention monsieur le sénateur sur la
couverture la protection des populations
la population de la protection vis-à-vis
du risque de contamination
c'est trop tôt 1 nous ne savons pas
encore véritablement si le vaccin en
plus de préserver des formes graves fait
chuter la contagiosité du virus et
préserve réforme bénie potentiellement
contaminante
on a des raisons d'espérer d'ailleurs de
façon générale on a le droit et même le
devoir d' espérer sentent désarmés et
c'est exactement ce qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui on a des raisons d'espérer
je disais puisque moderna a fait part et
celle ci c'est ce qui va là pour modern
age ii sera pour fiber vraisemblablement
nous a fait part de données qui
montrerait
réduction des contaminations j'étais
avec mon homologue israélien il ya deux
jours en visioconférence où il
partageait les informations observé en
israël parce que vous savez qu'un taux
de couverture vaccinale qui est
important ils ont d'ailleurs passé un
deal avec pfizer ils échangent des
données moyennant le un surplus de
vaccins ou wii voit on commence à
constater une réduction de la
contamination pas à 100% mais les
réductions la contamination ce qui
serait forcément une très très bonne
nouvelle et ce qui serait assez je
dirais conforme à l'histoire la
vaccination est l'impact des vaccins
depuis qu'ils existent ce serait tant
mieux
un moment aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup
trop c'est très prématuré vous imaginez
bien qu'on va pas commencer à de se
poser là ne serait-ce que se poser la
question de permettre l'accès à des
musées ou je ne sais quel rp ou à des
voyages à des gens qui seraient vaccinés
et surtout quand on vaccine des
personnes âgées en ehpad et sait si un
jour le taux de couverture vaccinale
devient élevé avec un taux d'adhésion la
population qui sera fort je vous le dis
le taux d'adhésion la population à la
vaccination sera beaucoup plus fort que
ce qu'on pouvait imaginer
en tout cas que ce que certains
imaginent et moi je fais partie de ceux
qui étaient plutôt croyant en la matière
ce que je crois au bon sens français
dans ce cas là peut-être qu'un jour la
question se posera mais comme
honnêtement je vais pas pousser le
raisonnement plus loin parce qu on est
dans du virtuel presque dans du dedans
un roman d'anticipation et donc il n'est
pas mais il ya des questions les
pays-bas qu'européen
les pays qui disent nous on a un bon
taux de couverture vaccinale
laissez-nous rentrée sans laissez nous
entrer sans test pcr la réponse est non
réponse est non on ne se désarme pas on
ne se désarme pas il ya aujourd'hui même
un conseil européen qui portera
notamment sur les politiques de tests
qui abordera la question des frontières
au sein de l'espace schengen mais aussi
pour l'extra union européenne
nous verrons ce qui ressortira du
travail de ce conseil européen important
sur l'identification des variants en
france nous déployons beaucoup beaucoup
de moyens et les scientifiques surtout
et avant tout pour augmenter nos
capacités séquençage génomique
l'angleterre est effectivement une bonne
un bon maillage et des bonnes
compétences des bonne capacité de
séquençage et c'est heureux nous sommes
loin d'être les derniers de l'europe en
matière d'équipement recettes ça fait
dix vingt trente ans que ces équipements
se met en place progressivement
je prends l'exemple par exemple de nos
voisins allemands on n'est pas moins
doté néanmoins il nous faut amplifier
nos capacité de séquençage génétique et
par ailleurs nous travaillons
d'arrache-pied avec les autorités de
santé pour valider en en avance de phase
des kits pcr permettant d'identifier les
variants sans avoir besoin de recourir
au séquençage génétique et ça je
souhaite ardemment que ce soit
opérationnel d'ici demain après quoi
nous déploierons donc ces kits qui
permettent de dépister les variants dans
les plateformes de laboratoires privés
et publics en privilégiant le territoire
ultramarin qu'il faut absolument
protéger de l'arrivée des variants et
les régions dans lesquelles le la
dynamique épidémique est la plus haute
où le taux d'épidémie le plus élevé
c'est-à-dire grand test bourgogne
franche comté aura et pour une partie
paca nous nous traquons sa variante nous
traquons jeu gta la rs ile-de-france
avant-hier en déplacement vous
n'imaginez pas vraiment les moyens
humains et technologiques qui sont mis
en place
en pratique pour traquer ces variants
c'est impressionnant juste pour
l'anecdote ya même une salle dans
laquelle vous avez cinq personnes qui
travaillent ou vous avez sur les murs
les plans des cockpits des avions selon
que ce soit des revues
des boeing et c'est avec les notices de
ventilation des cabines de ses avions
ils reçoivent les pochettes que
remplissent les passagers qui font des
vols internationaux avec l'oc leurs
coordonnées etc
et il y avait qu à partir du plan d'un
avion quand il ya une suspicion pas
forcément avec a confirmé me suspicion
de l'ariège non seulement ils appellent
la personne pour qu'ils ont mis pour
qu'il reste chez lui ils vont contacter
toutes les personnes qui selon la nature
du cockpit et la nature de ventilation
ont pu potentiellement être exposés à un
risque de transmission du variant les
rappels pour leur dire vous dirai ça l'
isolement vous tester immédiatement un
goûter c'est dans cette ville
quand je vous dis vous n'imaginez pas
c'est que mais moi qui pourtant connaît
bien le dossier avant d'aller voir sur
place les dizaines de personnes qui font
cela c'est très impressionnant à voir
ils font du d'ailleurs du traçage
rétrospectif le fameux traçage à la
japonaise
pour une fois qu'il ya quelqu'un qui est
positif non seulement identifier les
personnes que cette personne a pu
contaminer mais aussi à les rechercher
les personnes qui ont pu la contaminer
en l'occurrence c'était sur le marié ans
d'origine sud-africaine qui est un
variant qui à m'inquiéter en particulier
qu'on trouve moins que le variant angles
à ce stade
par ailleurs le variant angles âgés de
10 et tous les laboratoires sont
mobilisés pour nous permettre d'avoir
des indicateurs de suivi de croissance
du variant parce que je ne va pas se
mentir là le développement et la
propagation du variant d'origine
anglaise sur le territoire français
peut-être un élément déterminant dans
les stratégies de lutte contre
l'épidémie que nous pourrions déployés
dans les prochains jours et des
prochaines semaines
et si la part de variants c'est le voc
2020 devait augmenter de façon sensible
et que nous devions suivre une
trajectoire allant gleizes le
confinement deviendrait probablement une
nécessité absolue
donc nous traquons avait des données au
quotidien qui nous proviennent des labos
privés et publics et c'est une vraiment
quand je parle d'une course contre la
montre je pèse mes mots je sais que ce
que je dis généralement peu enfin
peut-être potentiellement suivi je le
dis parce que c'est un facteur
déterminant pour les jours les semaines
et les mois à venir et je parle aussi en
jour
sur la question des campagnes vaccinales
ma sénatrice bien sûr c'est pas une
mauvaise nouvelle si on peut utiliser le
vaccin chez d'autres publics que les
publics âgés c'est toujours des
personnes qu'on pourra protéger
supplémentaires j'ai juste qu'en termes
de clarté et lisibilité pour les gens il
faudra expliquer s'il est assez de cette
situation se présentait qu'on
commencerait à vacciner des gens de
moins de 60 ans avant de vacciner des
gens de plus de 60 ans alors même que
l'efsf le risque de formes graves sont
plus importants après 60 ans va faire si
le vaccin n'a pas de toutes les
garanties pour être utilisé chez les
gens plus de 60 ans on va pas se force à
l'utiliser chez eux donc on mènera des
campagnes en parallèle mais c'est juste
en termes de clarté et lisibilité
c'est quelque chose pour lequel il
faudra évidemment revenir devant les
français l'utilité de tous anti corrida
n'est plus à démontrer 12 millions et
demi d'utilisateurs 56000 notification
sans 2000 qu'a déclaré c'est beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup des
milliers des dizaines de milliers de
chaînes de contamination qui ont pu être
évités grâce à tous sortis qu'au vite
est-ce que c'est exhaustif en tout cas
c'est fonctionnel
moi je lai sur mon téléphone j'imagine
que vous aussi et vous avez accès aux
données que vient de jeu je viens de
vous donner comme n'importe quel citoyen
nous sommes monsieur le sénateur déjà
sur un rythme de plus d'un million de
personnes vaccinées par mois nous aurons
dépassé largement le million et
effectivement après vous raconter les
primo vaccination les rappels de
vaccination etc
mais vous avez raison voilà à par
semaine et ça va oui en terme d'arrivées
jadot on aura une période je vous le dis
parce que c'est ce qui se passe aussi à
l'étranger c'est ce que nous avons tous
prévus dès lors qu'on est en flux tendu
et qu'on doit garder des doses pour
faire des rappels vaccinaux on aura une
période en février où on aura une espèce
de petit creux dans la courbe des primo
vaccination
vous aurez paradoxalement alors qu'on
aura plus de vaccins - de nouvelles
personnes primo vacciner qu'aujourd'hui
on est sur un rythme là qui est très
élevé mais le rythme sera bien plus
faible dans les dents les autres courant
du mois de février dès lors je regardais
que l'allemagne fait cinquante mille
primo vaccination depuis deux jours
alors qu'elle était bien au delà les
jours précédents parce que quand on
arrive à woodstock
non pas août stocks mais à bout de stoke
vous forcément vous avez moins de
vaccins a proposé aux personnes qui
n'ont pas encore été du tout vacciner
pour privilégier les rappels enfin sur
maintenant je crois j'ai répondu je
crois que j'ai répondu à vos questions
merci messieurs les signes at il
d'autres
d'autres questions oui madame dormait
dit merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre vous dit que quand quand il
ya des cas qui sont dits peuvent par
exemple dans les avions
quand on l'appelle tout le monde et on
leur dit qu'ils doivent s'isoler et c
est après i 6o ici seuls pas où et
contrôle et où l isolement
les gens les gens que vous prévenez qui
a auquel on de vente de s'isoler
donc est-ce qui s'isole comment le
savez-vous et de quelle manière comptez
vous les pays qui ont réussi ce sont les
pays qui ont obligé les gens à se
confier à fin à ces assises au lait qui
les ont mis dans des hôtels qui les ont
mis dans des lieux vous vous vous prenez
l'avion vous allez à singapour vous vous
avez un
vous avez un autobus qui vous attend à
l'arrivée pour vous emmener dans un
hôtel et vous y restez 14 jours et si
vous être contaminés vous allez
directement à l'hôpital
et si vous avez si vous n'êtes qu'à
contacter vous devez vous isolez vous
êtes contrôlés vous avez un
comment ça s'appelle un bracelet
électronique etc
ah ouais là ce sont des pays qui
réussissent ils nous pas on a su me
permettront à thèse antithèse alors
monsieur le sénateur ghz et ça ne
marchait pas et que s'aggraver j'ai
essayé de faire une synthèse si oui si
on m'y a autorisé un la france pendant
tout le début de la première vague
souvenez-vous phase 1 phases 2d que nous
avions un cas positif il était
hospitalisé
ça n'a pas échappé ça n'a pas empêché la
première vague les pays qui autour de
nous ont mis des contraintes à
l'isolément sont aujourd'hui parmi les
pays qui ont la troisième vague la plus
violente
la plus jeune il ya mille puisse 1500
morts par jour en angleterre où il a pu
y avoir des mesures de contrainte
l'espagne a été obligé de confiner et je
regardais hier un tableau qui montrait
que sur 32 pays du continent européen
nous étions 32e
depuis plusieurs jours en terme de
mortalité de cas graves tant mieux les
32e dans le bon sens on en parle moins
mais c'est un fait
quant au pays - damas sénatrice en asie
qui ont mis en place parfois ilham
l'armée mobilisée dans les rues c'est un
peu peut-être un petit côté opio gêne
j'ai lu que la chine construisait un
centre pour pouvoir isoler des plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes c'est
pas le choix que nous faisons c'est pas
le choix que vous avez fait en tout cas
vos présidents de groupes ont fait dans
leur quasi totalité qui nous ont demandé
de ne pas recourir à ce type de mesures
ce qui moi me mettrai à l'aise parce que
je ne le souhaite pas je suis vraiment
pas convaincu que ce soit efficace pour
les bonnes raisons que c'est ça qui a
évoqué tout à l'heure à monsieur le
sénateur que si on vous dit que si vous
dites que vous êtes malade on va vous
isoler dans un hôtel où on va vous
mettre c'est très compliqué par contre
nous avons fait non seulement le choix
de la confiance mais le choix de
l'accompagnement la sénatrice +2 94% des
gens qui sont cas positifs ou qu'à
contacter reçoivent dans les 24 heures
un premier appel qui vient de
l'assurance maladie ou de la rs qui le
raf qui les informe qu'ils n'ont pas de
rupture de droits nous sommes le seul
cri ou n'avait même pas deux jours de
carence et vous pouvez le faire vous
enregistrer directement sur internet
pour que sur votre simple déclaration
vous puissiez vous isolez sans perte de
droit et nous mettons en place et nous
renforçons le système testé alerté
protéger en déployant des infirmières au
domicile des personnes lorsqu'elles sont
mises à l'isolément pour pouvoir aller
tester jusqu'à l'entourage familial dans
le foyer même de la personne qui est
positif avec un accompagnement qui peut
être quotidien tant sur le plan
sanitaire et sur le plan social avec des
possibilités aussi d'accueil et
d'hébergement pour des gens quand ils ne
savent pas être isolé dans de bonnes
conditions chez eux dans des structures
hôtelières dans le croyez moi
l'accompagnement il est très bien fait
et je vous assure que l'expérience cette
fois ci nous permet de dire avec
certitude que l' isolement contrainte ne
protège pas un pays d'une vague et parmi
le pays vous avez cités comme singapour
ou le japon qui procèdent à des
isolements contrainte ils ont confiné
ils ont confiné beaucoup ils ont confiné
forts et ils ont confiné aussi longtemps
pour certains d'autres pas tous mais
certains d'entre eux donc ce n'est pas
la martingale
merci monsieur mais une dernière
question de madame la sénatrice à remake
est en visio conférence
j'espère qu'elle va prendre la parole ce
sera la dernière
merci vous avez l'intention
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je ce matin tôt on avait une
audition dans le cadre de la commission
des affaires européennes avec le
directeur général au service de la santé
à la commission européenne
monsieur delsaux est une question lui a
été posée sur la possibilité pour la
commission d'assurer une plus grande
transparence sur le contrôle
démocratique sur les contrats passés
pour avec les laboratoires pour les
vaccins et il a répondu dans un langage
fort diplomatique que vous connaissez
bien de bruxelles qu en fait le problème
n'était pas le problème de la
transparence européenne mais plutôt un
problème de transparence des états
membres donc je voulais savoir comment
vous réagissiez à 7
cette réponse là et puis la deuxième
question que je vais vous poser il ya
une communication d'un de la commission
européenne qui a été arrêté hier et
diffusant diffusé hier en préalable la
réunion de ce soir avec notamment la
préparation de deux règlements qui qui
semble vouloir donner plus de pouvoirs à
la commission européenne en matière de
coordination des plans de santé de
renforcement de la deûle un delaune de
de la commission européenne en matière
de pénurie de médicaments et en matière
de plan de vaccination et monsieur
delsaux disait avoir les vaccins tête
c'est une chose tout le problème c'est
la transparence sur les plans de
vaccination
je voulais savoir aussi comment vous
vous vous réagissiez à ça et quelle sera
la position du gouvernement français sur
ces questions là je vous remercie
infiniment c'est monsieur le ministre
en une minute la sénatrice sont
accessibles à tout à chacun en toute
transparence les critères de
responsabilité des laboratoires qui
produisent et vendent les vaccins
les prix d'acquisition des vaccins par
la commission européenne
les volumes acquis et précommander en
vaccins par la commission européenne
les délais et les rythmes de livraison
de ces différents vaccins ainsi que
l'ensemble des dates à des données
scientifiques et médicales qui ont
permis à l' agence du médicament
européenne en transparence et en open
data de valider et d'autoriser ces
vaccins je ne sais pas ce qui manque
je ne sais pas ce qui manque
j'ai honnêtement quand on je les
personnes qui savent ce que c'est qu'un
contrat public le comprennent
quand il ya une mise en concurrence pour
passer des contrats qui représentent en
l'occurrence des milliards ou des
dizaines de milliards d'euros
il y à une partie des informations
industrielles et commerciales fournis
par chacun des candidats pour passer les
contrats qui n'ont pas être mis sur le
domaine public sa maman parce que la pr
au prochain appel d'offres sapho serait
la comble la concurrence est là et la
liberté de l'autorité qui portent procès
nos acquisitions donc ça c'est la limite
mais venir entre adultes pardon on va
tout le monde dans les responsables
publics c'est ça depuis des dizaines
d'années qui font semblant de continuer
à s' étonné je vais complètement
vous avez parfaitement raison monsieur
le sénateur mais là en plus je me
positionnais de la part du côté du
citoyen qu'est ce qui est intéressant
qu'est ce que moi
j'ai besoin de savoir pour être rassurés
sur je connais les prix les volumes les
délais les rythmes les dogues des
données et le volet critères de
responsabilité appliquée aux
laboratoires
je réponds je cherche je ne vois pas ce
qui est susceptible de m'intéresser en
plus alors peut-être qu'il ya des gens
qui sont intéressés par d'autres
informations
effectivement ça relève de du droit des
droits de la concurrence l'europe est
une chance en santé est une opportunité
formidable en santé et leur a pas trop
longtemps mis la santé de côté
considérant qu est l affaire d etat les
inégalités de santé en europe sont
beaucoup trop importante en partagent la
même monnaie mais pas la même espérance
de vie
il s'assied pas d'uniformiser les
systèmes de protection sociale la france
en ce sens un système le plus protecteur
et c'est tant mieux c'est historique
mais on a beaucoup de coopération à
mener ensemble à l'échelle européenne en
matière de politique sanitaire enfin en
termes de recherche aussi une recherche
recherche et développement et puis je
pense que l'expérience a montré à finhan
foncé le clou quand on disait depuis des
années qu'il fallait qu'on retrouve de
l'autonomie en matière de production de
médicaments en matière de l'an est
également en matières premières et en
matériel de protection
il faut évidemment qu'on serait
industrialise et qu'on soit capable de
retrouver la souveraineté en matière de
médicaments on peut pas être dépendant
de trois états dans le monde quand c'est
en plus la chine l'inde et le pakistan a
enfin finalisé
donc il faut qu'on ait une stratégie
européenne qui soit marquée en la
matière qu'on l'assument
c'est moi je suis un européen convaincu
donc je pense qu'on peut vraiment
progresser en la matière et tout ce qui
va permettre de le renforcer
la france prendra la présidence
française de l'union européenne
commencera dans quelques mois j'ai déjà
des réunions préparatoires avec mes
homologues saleh ceux qui nous précèdent
et ceux qui nous succèdent de matière à
bâtir un plan stratégique sur plusieurs
années en matière de coopération
européenne en santé nous avons des
objectifs qui sont ambitieux et je crois
profondément que ce sera beaucoup plus
efficace pour nos populations
je remercie mesdames et messieurs merci
monsieur le ministre vien l'audition est
terminée je rappelle que le texte en
commission mardi en séance mercredi
[Musique]